anyone can make themselves a millionaire
the trade to a million dollars is insane
but it's still possible for them to do
it it's possible but to say anyone how
are people going to in a third world
country make money to be a millionaire
and maybe the way to become a
millionaire from one of those countries
is get out of the country you can't just
get out of the country I'm somebody
oh hey there did you know that with ai's
advancement you too can be a millionaire
or at least work like one let me tell
you how
but first we'd like to thank Google for
sponsoring this portion of the video
with all this recent Buzz around AI it
may seem new but fun fact Google's been
a leader in AI for years and what's Wild
is that AI can be used for so many
things from making a huge impact at a
large scale to enhancing our day-to-day
lives for example Google is building a
number of tools to help in the medical
field they're working on research for
things like helping detect diseases
earlier and combat health issues like
breast cancer okay I'm not a doctor but
that doesn't mean I can't use Google's
AI myself how because Google is
developing generative AI tools for
brainstorming proofreading and writing
in docs slides sheets Gmail and More in
Google workspace also have you ever
needed crucial advice but your friends
literally take five business days to
respond well get ready to meet Bard an
AI experiment by Google where you can
ask things like how do I become content
creator or how do I get my baby to stop
crying like literally my baby can't stop
crying and it'll generate a response as
if you're just chatting with a friend
thank you Bard doesn't this sound like
Google's AI is already making life
better learn more about what Google is
doing in AI at ai.google
thanks again to Google for sponsoring
this portion of the video now
let's get into the episode
[Music]
I would only date a millionaire
three two one
go
hell no oh crap the person I want to
date I want to be able to show them you
know all those experiences firsthand
like I've been with girls who have money
and it's like
the worst thing ever like for example
like the one thing for me and it's a
test I do is like for example if a girl
knows how to get into my car like my
Lamborghini like you have to like
specifically know how to open the door I
specifically let them figure it out if
they figure it out that's the last one
that's the last date seriously that's
the last day we're going on I want my
husband to be like a really good dad and
be like morally correct and if he
doesn't have a lot of money you know
what that's fine I don't know if men
really are comfortable with that to be
completely honest from my personal
experience they're not they want to be
the ones providing which kind of sucks
but you know personality and morals and
like their mindset is way more important
than money I feel like money doesn't
define a person at all like if I'm gonna
date you it's for your personality not
your looks not your money I don't care
from personal experience money has
absolutely nothing to do with a
relationship so um I agree with you guys
but as a woman I don't want to be the
one paying the bills and taking care of
their house and so for me like you don't
have to be the richest person in the
world but if I'm going to be a
millionaire or more timeline or whatever
it is I at least want to be the person
that encourages you to do the same but I
don't want to be
I just I've I've had it done before and
it's been the most exhausting thing
because it's like you can be the
sweetest man ever but if we go out and
I'm paying for everything and I'm doing
everything it's too much that's why I'm
just like I somewhat agreed that I need
you to be a millionaire at least be
making enough money to where I'm fully
taken care of and then we can be a
Powerhouse together like Beyonce and
Jay-Z So I think yeah I think a lot of
the times it's different from a girl's
perspective versus a guy I think girls
want to be taken care of I think that's
a beautiful thing I've always just been
the one to take care of girls and pay
for everything I think it's just I think
as a guy you should be doing that but I
mean on this topic my point is you
brought up something of saying oh if the
girl doesn't know how to open up my car
door I wouldn't even date her but I feel
like you know I feel like it's ever so
selfish because you feel like oh I want
to get Happiness by making this girl uh
you know spending money on her at the
same time I feel like the only binding
factor in your relationship is money at
that point right because if you stop
providing money to her then she gets
used to that lifestyle then she's like
okay I'm gonna find someone else the
reason I say that is because I feel I
wasn't looking at like a sense of like
that but more like getting used for it
like girls will want to go on dates with
you because you can take them to that
dinner you know they can they want all
of that so I feel like that's very
common that they will use you for that
and it's like a it's a thing I'm scared
of you know like it's happened to me
many times so it's like I said it like
that and it sounded kind of crazy
um and everyone was like oh what the
hell but like you know what I mean you
know like it's common girls will only
come to you because you have the lambo
because you make the money exactly and
they don't care about you you know so
that's what I was kind of going at I
like a girl who just doesn't care about
money at all you know something that I
do whenever I meet people is I don't
tell them my name I don't tell them my
Instagram I don't want them to be able
to search me up know how much money I
make know where I live and know the
lifestyle that I live because that's how
I avoid people using me for money yeah I
have two different Instagrams so like me
too I have one instagram I'll send to
them and like if you know it's kind of
tests you know if they look through it
there's no cars nothing flashy it's like
me and my mom and like Marshall's
clothing and like if they if they with
that like then we then we go on you know
yeah no I I actually have a rule if you
know who I am you're officially like off
the lit like I cannot talk to you at all
um because oh my God what happens is
poor guy in the past like when I've met
guys and they know like what I do we'll
go out and I'm like okay we're going out
to dinner you know I mean I look nice
everything and then they're like so do
you know if you could teach me how to
trade oh and I'm like okay and it's just
like Dread the rest of the night no no
no no like there's a guy that like pulls
out like a notebook
yeah
my name is Kelly OG and I am the biggest
secret that you've probably never heard
which is okay because it's a secret my
net worth is about 20 million dollars
what do you think makes you a great
entrepreneur
my relentlessness to never give up I've
never believed that I couldn't do
anything even in the cases where it was
probably not the most likely I've just
always worked towards it saying one day
it's going to come and I think that work
ethic and tenacity just continued to
compound and roll over and snowball
itself into what I have today
it is easier to make money if you're
white
three two one
go
my mentor is not white and he's worth
204 million dollars so I think I've seen
it firsthand you know most of my friend
group is not whites and they do very
well for themselves I would say you're
almost an exception with what the
majority is I think majority wise if you
look at just the demographic of the
United States you know whenever you
think of trust fund babies whenever you
think of houses in the Hamptons and
everything of that luxury lifestyle it's
not usually the black demographic or
people of color in general for example
when slavery was a thing white people
had a 200 year Head Start to start their
businesses to set up their families for
success and all that so when black
people finally had the opportunities
which was not until recently 1965 to
really be in the same rooms as white
people you're looking at a large
discrepancy in time and success and
achievement so I think just naturally in
general white people are taking is more
serious because of the stereotypes that
have been put on people of color so
that's where I'm like I agree with that
statement not saying that people of
color cannot be successful but just
saying that it's more likely for someone
who is white to have better
opportunities than someone who isn't I
mean maybe in past Generations what
you're saying is 100 True right if
you're based on race people perceive you
differently I feel like now this new
generation you can become wealthy from
the internet right like you're on Forex
I'm in crypto I don't have to have any
face on the products I create it doesn't
matter what race I am because if they
don't know who I am selling the products
to them I I don't think it's that you
know a values of point today than it
used to be in previous generations I
agree your your face doesn't always have
to be tied to it so
I mean she changed my mind a little bit
because I feel like I was a little bit
too harsh because you did make like a
really good point statistically you were
150 correct like you were right but I
think in my first hand experience just
the people I've been around a lot of
them are not white and they are
successful so that's why I was like so
yeah all the way to the right now I'm
like here I think we forget that not
everybody's job is online and not
everybody's job you can hide behind a
screen and most people work everyday
jobs in person doing you know customer
service where people have to look at
them so I think if we're talking about
if it's easier to make money as a white
person I would say yes because applying
to jobs most of the time if they go into
an interview and their person of color
they're probably Mo like less likely to
get that job than a white person and
also a white person is probably going to
get paid more than a person of color
we've seen it in the statistics so I
think it is easier to make more money as
a white person I think two things
specifically for one although I'm right
here Indians make the most amount of
money in America when it comes to any
racial demographic Group which is great
so shout out to the Indians but two with
that being said I remember when I
started my business I had a very
in-depth conversation with my father and
he said Jay if I were you I would highly
recommend staying behind the scenes of
letting a right a white man run the
business because they get along with
people a little bit better than we do
just because people don't understand
Indians but even in that you could you
know develop yourself to be a great CEO
regardless I mean there's huge companies
in America that they're all ran by
Indian Americans or Indian Starbucks I
mean whether it's Google whether it's
Microsoft I mean these are all ran by
Indian Americans I'm Jay I'm the CEO and
principal of bodair a quick 30 seconds
in regards to who I am I started
programming at the age of nine at 11 I
started freelancing I got my first
contract with a local Salon to build
their website and then at 14 is when I
got my first large contract with a
Fortune 500 company at 15 I dropped at
high school to pursue my agency
full-time and at 18 I moved to Dallas
Texas I'm originally from Pennsylvania
I'm Isabella and I'm a designer on
entrepreneur and reality TV star I
started out on reality TV on the show
Toddlers and Tiaras I was six years old
when I was named one of the youngest
self-made Millionaires and I really
loved fashion so I created my first
brand which was a suit and Blazer line
sold that to JCPenney for private
labeling started a jewelry company where
your wings accomplishment bracelets I
created House of bready which is now my
Global business which has made me more
than a million now and I'm also writing
a book called a teen's guide to business
to show people how to become who I am
today
I have flaunted my wealth
three two one go
I was bullied as a kid so flaunting my
wealth was kind of my way of saying hey
I made it and I kind of looking back at
it I wasn't as satisfied as I thought I
would be like I thought like oh I got
the lambo and like everyone's like oh my
God you know I agree and like I feel
like I don't flaunt it but like I've
worked very hard so if I want to post my
nice car I'm gonna post my nice car
because I made the money to buy that I
want to post me buying something at
Gucci I'm gonna do that because I worked
hard for that it's not flaunting it's
more of like self you know you're proud
yeah I'm proud of it exactly do you ever
feel guilty doing that because sometimes
yeah oh my God like I I agree with you
on the I used to get bullied like crazy
I I just feel I feel guilty because I'm
like some people just will they won't
have this opportunity or maybe they will
but I just like my mindset around it I
feel bad sometimes but at the same time
it's not like we're trust fund kids we
worked for it anyone have a trust fund
I wish no no
okay continue
I definitely remember when I first
started making a little bit of money I
would have those little corny Instagram
flexes on your story um I will lie
it definitely was it was like on the
steering wheel yeah right it was like
asking it's like it's not a big deal
it's not a big deal but uh I think as I
as I've grown up a little bit it's it's
not really I don't I don't do it as much
I've just posted a video Flying first
class almost every single one of my
thumbnails have NYC Penthouse in it so I
do I even strongly agree because I do
flaunt it but for me the reason why I do
it is first of all it's clickable
everyone wants to you know see how does
she do that but also people can go back
and see how I started and see how I grew
myself up to there and I get a lot of
comments all the time being like wow
it's so cool seeing you grow up from
living in your friend's basement to now
a penthouse and I think the difference
for me instead of feeling like I'm
showing off and stuff is because I'm
showing people how I did it in hopes to
inspire people
um that aren't living this lifestyle
that maybe live the lifestyle that I
used to that it is achievable and that
if they want to live this lifestyle
potentially they could
my name is mai I'm a YouTuber and I'm
also the founder of my clothing line
alkaline I'm 20 years old now but I made
my first million when I was 18. I've
just been doing YouTube for a very very
long time but I feel like when I was
younger and I wasn't making that much
money I learned how to budget my money a
lot so honestly what drives me to do
what I do every single day is just to be
able to provide for the people around me
and to be able to inspire as many
creatives as I possibly can like that is
my main motive at this point it's not
for financial purposes anymore
my name is Yusuf and I am a crypto
entrepreneur I was learning stocks and
investing at quite young age around 10
years old and
um am I going to drop shipping then
after around maybe like 20 attempts of
failed Source I had to one really big
hit I then when 2018 I bought Bitcoin
ethereum and other altcoins like silico
and V chain and in 2021
um I created my own cryptocurrency and I
started helping crypto other people by
building their cryptos for them it was
like you know it was a level up system I
did this then I went to that I wanted
that and it just kept progressingly
getting better I feel we should do a
group trip to St Parts no like please we
should actually absolutely y'all your
pain right of course
Liz Liz are you free next week we're all
going to same bars we'd love for you to
come oh yeah yeah I'd love to let me
just like uh we'll collect all my credit
cards oh we should actually you know how
crazy
we'll go here to Miami dude all right
all right we'll make it happen all right
all right let's get serious guys this is
what do you mean
I would be a different person if I
didn't have this money
three two one go
shoot if I have money or not I'm still
the same person I always preach on my
social media just be authentic and be
you and people will love you for who you
are
I think for me when I didn't have money
and I was living at my parents house I
had a lot of mental health issues I was
depressed and I was suicidal and I think
having the money to be able to move
myself out of that environment
completely changed my life having money
has boosted my confidence so much just
in a way where I have a nose job so I
was able to do that and I used to look
in the mirror every single day and just
cry and cry and cry because I thought I
was so ugly and having money now to be
able to live wherever I want live with
whoever I want and being able to you
know change things about my appearance
so I think that money completely changed
my life and without it my personality
wouldn't even be the same because when I
was younger and I was in that toxic
household where my parents were arguing
about money every single day that made
me such a Negative person I was not the
optimistic positive person that I am
today and I think that having money and
getting myself out of that has
completely changed my personality you
know I would agree money gives you a lot
of opportunities it allows you to afford
a lot of things get out of different
environments and I want that experience
for everyone so I love that you were
able to take care of not only your
family but how your confidence is and
allows you to hold your head higher I
love that for you I think there's a
saying that money doesn't change you it
amplifies who you already are if you're
usually a selfish person you're gonna
think everybody sees you for the money
for the most part you're going to think
everyone needs to owe you if you're a
cocky person you're going to make the
money to find who you are just to kind
of piggyback off of what you said I
genuinely feel like I'm the same kid as
I was when I started programming at the
age of nine like just a hard-working kid
that wanted to make something out of
himself if I feel as if I was just in
college right now I would still be like
working hard at school trying to improve
myself I'm still the same guy I might
dress a little bit nicer or eat better
food but fundamentally the same kid yeah
um I I 100 agree with what you're saying
that you know your fundamentals stay the
same but to say you were the same person
when you were nine to you until you were
now right I mean like I feel like let's
I don't know maybe there's an alternate
version of yourself that wasn't
successful if you go look at that have a
conversation with that person you can't
say oh me and him are the same I feel
like to be strongly disagrees a bit more
harsh I feel like you know I feel like
experiences have definitely shaped your
being right yeah I'm trying to think of
where I would be at like I feel like yes
I still am the same it's very fair yeah
I feel like I still am the same person
like I still like the same things but
like he said experience is a hundred
percent shape you like the people you're
around oh yeah that rubs off and right
now my like my best friends in high
school are like cracking like a hundred
beers a day and like posting on their
Snapchat story it's like I would be with
them right now so I would 100 not be the
same person you know now I'm doing
different things that's a really good
example so I feel as if although the
experience would be different as an
individual I genuinely feel I'm the same
guy always worked hard I mean I have
immigrant parents I always had a little
bit of a burden on my head it
transitioned very organically for me to
become an entrepreneur and I think
that's the difference but that's why I
also had to go to disagree in terms of
actually maybe I'll go to somewhere one
question you've been talking about work
ethic a lot but do you think that it's
change your confidence or the way you
view certain things like aside from work
do you think it's changed you work I
think I think is single-handedly the
most important thing when it comes to
any success in life like I used to be a
very chubby and overweight guy I got my
together and dropped my ignorance
did all the research and I ended up
getting into really good shape so that
all really just comes from your work
ethic at the end of the day as a society
the number one thing we Chase is money
because money is what all of our
problems kind of lie under what the
bills lie under what just living a life
lies under what eating lies under and so
for a lot of people they don't have the
opportunities they don't have the
freedom they don't have the breathing
room so every single day is just chasing
money and living paycheck to paycheck
when you do have money you can take the
step back and be like okay all of that's
taken care of let me focus on me let me
focus on my relationships let me focus
on repairing things so I think that's
that's a really big privilege that I
think we do have and I think it's
subjected to all of us like we all have
different experiences so I think money
has changed people but I think the
connotation is always a bad thing and
that's that's why people fight so hard
for no money hasn't changed me but I
think even when money does change you it
can be for good exactly you know and so
I think it's just subjective to how we
feel individually about it I feel like
all of us are very like open to
conversation and no one's arrogant or
like being rude so very happy I was a
little scared walking into this were you
guys was anyone else scared a little
yeah oh there was sfx going on in my ear
going
that was my heart that was my heart I
was nervous I said I was like I'm not
shy but I'm I'm like scared of what
other people think of me in a way
overall it's been pretty great so far so
excited for the rest so far reset
I'm Fiona I'm a founder and CEO I'm also
a YouTuber so I started making money at
the age of eight from acting and
modeling then I started making more
money at the age of 10 uh from YouTube
by the age of 18 I became a millionaire
through YouTube AdSense sponsorships my
brand and now it is expanding a lot so
it's growing quickly which is really
insane and I'm still 19. I'm still a
teenager
I am lonely
three two one go
oh man
forget y'all
I think like in a work aspect no I'm not
lonely in a personal aspect absolutely
like a lot of my friends we don't do the
same things I love them to death they
have great morals they're great people
but like mentally wise it's very
different and like a little I just feel
different I feel lonely I prefer being
kind of alone oh me too I've grown to
like it I enjoy it a lot I enjoy it to
be honest with you like sometimes I
literally just want to go out at night
and just drive alone or just be in my
house alone I'm kind of an anti-social
person because I was forced to be like
that as a young kid because people did
not like me they bullied me they did not
want to spend time with me so I guess
that kind of molded me into being like
preferring to be alone it's hard to find
like-minded 18 19 and 20.
completely I was like that's like the
first time
I don't lonely
25 26.
oh my God they're all about to have like
kids
and like this is like the first time
I've been able to have like an educated
conversation with someone my age like
usually in 18 19 years like yeah dude
college party man tonight like let's go
like you know this is like only in that
sense too I think when it comes to
actually having friends
foreign
because there's always a difference I
mean if you're talking about it gets to
the point if I want to hang out with my
friends then I'm the one paying for
everything and it's a really difficult
position for me like one of my biggest
prayers that I've been praying for like
the last year is for God to introduce me
to girlfriends like friends that are
girls that are doing the same thing I'm
doing they're doing really well I think
it's awesome that you know we're on this
road I'm yeah I'm happy that we all did
this yeah yeah so when you guys aren't
lonely like you don't like to be lonely
I feel like I thought you were gonna be
like you're a crypto Trader
I mean like I enjoy my own company you
know I love just spending time myself
going to walk Etc but like I am have big
networks of other like-minded crypto
people and different Traders so I'm
maybe I'm blessed in that sense like
maybe some of you are saying like I know
you were saying that you don't have
people you could talk to about like your
age who are like you know in the Forex
industry uh and I feel like I'm
surrounded with a lot of people maybe
they are older but I don't mind that I
don't mind having friends with 24 25 26
you know you don't I do I don't feel
like they don't have the same problems
as me like you know what I mean like I'm
like I'm still trying to find like my
first girlfriend that's gonna last more
than yeah but there are 17 once right or
or they were 17 18 ones so yeah it's not
it's different when you're not in the
same because they look they look at you
different you know they look at you as
like a son or like that's that's my
relationship with series of friends like
they're my mentors I look up to them for
business advice so there's a little bit
of a personal disconnect that I feel you
know yeah I'm surprised you guys don't
feel that that's why I was so shocked do
you guys think you had a childhood
no yeah what was that yeah
no not really I don't think I had a
child I also think I forced myself to
not have a childhood because I was just
always like well I need to become
somebody and I need to take care of my
family so like it was and wasn't that's
just always me I mean I think I always
had like an underlying pressure being
from an immigrant family to always like
try to succeed but I mean I think I had
a great childhood I mean I I have two
older sisters that I spend time with I
played basketball did track did the
whole nine yards and then I think my
childhood really ended probably when I
was like in seventh grade after that I
just was focused a lot on business no no
I'm like I'm grateful for the childhood
like I had but I don't think it's
traditional whatsoever it's so different
like I put like every element of myself
online for people to judge and
um it was hard it was really hard but I
still had fun like I definitely did
stupid things which I'm very I'm so
grateful for I look back and I'm like
yeah okay I had fun still which is
really what matters to me would you
trade your money for your childhood no
no no no I thought about it no no really
for me I didn't really have very much of
a childhood because my parents were
working from morning to night so that's
why I went online to seek a community
and people to talk to I would play games
on my PC and stream that to talk to
people and that's where I am today but
that's also the reason why my mom lives
with me now is because I feel like she
never got to raise me and I never got a
mother figure in my life so that's kind
of why I'm mending that relationship now
so that we both feel like you know
she was my parents I've thought about it
well like definitely like sometimes like
when when I call like my friends that
are in college and they're telling me
like their biggest problem is like their
history test I'm like
yeah please bro please make me that make
that my problem like my biggest priority
you know so sometimes when I think on
that standpoint I definitely consider it
like yeah the money's great everything's
great but again we all kind of talked
about like how much do we value money
like sometimes I do value the other
things as well like the actual personal
experiences you know I wouldn't mind
being with my friends right now in the
basement you know watching sports and
you know hanging out like I would not
mind that at all like but you know we
all make that we make the hard decisions
that's the thing we all made the hard
decision and you know I mean we we're
all faced with very tough challenges and
problems yeah but we also get the other
half of that which is all the success
yeah notoriety comes with it
hi I'm Aaron I'm an entrepreneur in the
e-commerce space and a business
consultant for a great entrepreneur you
definitely have to be a kind of a to
your own you know you have to be a
person that is able to motivate yourself
being able to be alone a lot of people
aren't able to not be social so
anti-social I think is kind of with it
like when I see people that are
entrepreneurs if they can't be on their
own they are going to struggle
anyone can make themselves a millionaire
three two one go
[Music]
really
so high there's so much free advertising
what's your argument to say that not
everyone can make themselves a
millionaire is it the like not a quality
thing or like resources if you really
look at the likelihood you have to make
a thousand dollars a thousand times
which is just insane like
I think everyone can try their hardest
but you won't always get the right
exposure to have a million dollars put
into you won't always get the right
opportunities it's easy for us because
we've done it to be like well I did it
so anybody else can do it but there are
many people that do exactly what we do
but yet you are in the position you're
in for a reason there's a lot of people
that build apps and have like a company
surrounded by that there's a lot of
people that have done crypto and now
their lives are in shambles there's a
lot of people that have done Drop
Shipping and it was the worst thing they
ever did there's a lot of people that
have built different companies and it
was next to nothing and there's millions
and millions of bloggers on YouTube
and it's amounted to nothing even for me
there I know so many people that trade
and I'm like it's going to be very hard
for you to get to where I'm at because I
traded and built a company but to trade
to a million dollars is insane but it's
still possible for them to do it now
it's possible but to say anyone
but also technically like if you're
looking at a standpoint anybody can you
know the reason why I mean I also think
I'm very privileged to be honest with
you because I have like my my mentor he
comes from like the projects like
from the project and he's worth nine
figures so for me I go if he came from
that circumstance in life but I also
think that most of us are in the US and
that's where a lot of money is made but
a lot of people don't get granted a visa
to come here think about the people that
don't have internet they don't have the
library to go to to get the internet and
also think about the people that from
their family situation
um for some reason now they're homeless
and in order to people always say well
then get a job but in order to get a job
you need to be able to have a home
address and not everybody has that it's
just those little things that we don't
think about to even get to that first
step of getting a job but here's the
thing right like you were mentioning
earlier you're basically saying that's
oh people's life from channels because
crypto or Forex but it's very rarely the
the mistake of external factors is
because they did a mistake along the way
right they were too Reckless with the
research and they just dumps all their
money into it I feel like the reason why
I'm here I wish there's maybe another
one but it's because
um I feel like it is possible but
depending on your circumstance it could
be exponentially harder right if you're
like someone from like Ethiopia who has
no internet access for instance and it's
going to be so much harder but it's
still possible I mean if you'd like if
you recommend they should do
because I'm Nigerian I recently just
came from Nigeria they get paid like a
hundred dollars a month and that's
insane to them so I feel like if you're
gonna say okay well if you don't have
internet access it's still possible give
an example of how it's possible I know
someone who's actually Nigerian but then
there was a public library he went to
which was like three hours away and he
created cryptocurrency from that so
while I feel like to say it's impossible
is too much because I believe nothing in
this universe is impossible there's
always a certain extent where something
can be achieved I think you know even
the most crazy situation is 99.99
impossible but nothing's 100 possible
right so I feel like to say there's a
type of person that can 100 count to be
a millionaire is very rare but it's not
about making money there's a certain
person like a millionaire that's that's
a crazy completely different yeah but
anything's possible I think okay if
somebody asked you right to put it in
your terms what is your prediction for
Bitcoin for example you wouldn't tell
them anything's possible could go to 100
million no you would actually back it up
with actual like facts and statistics
just why so when and I think of just
logically thinking can anyone become a
millionaire it's like you want to back
that up and if you say I mean yeah they
really get paid and they don't live in a
house and they're eating and drinking
water from a river but anything's
possible it's like where do you think
somebody's going to magically come down
and be like this is how you're going to
get from me I think it's also a mindset
I think truly it's a mindset like you
have to be mentally strong enough to go
through the work put like at you're all
into something pause
um can you uh choose a side if you can
it's a hard question no I'm staying in
the middle
defend it
there you go
I mean I just haven't done research on
third world countries but if you like it
is possible like again you may have to
take that four hour walk to that pop-up
library with like one antenna or
whatever the case may be but again it's
possible yeah but at the same time like
she shifted me up on this side because
uh what she said is 100 true you know it
is theoretically possible you know just
even though it isn't anyone can become a
millionaire you know because like if
even at 0.001 chance let's say you have
the worst situation possible even though
you know it is theoretically possible
and in real world scenario that's not
true it's like saying you know what's
the probability you roll a dice and then
it lands on the edge instead of any
other number while there's like a really
small probability at the same time you
can't say oh yeah it's possible it's
possible you know because it's like such
a small chance which is why I'm more on
this side now yeah I think I just
recently took a trip back to Vietnam and
my parents immigrated from there and I
think I just realized that you guys are
talking about these online services make
money make money but a lot of places
don't even have Banks they run on cash
do you need a bank to be a millionaire I
think
no because cash but then how are people
going to in those notes that's true make
money to be a millionaire and maybe the
way to become a millionaire from one of
those countries is get out of the
country but you can't just get out of
the country I'm somebody that had to
wait two years yeah I'm somebody that
had to wait like two to three years to
be able to get my Visa and now I'm
granting my employees visas my parents
visas and it's a very difficult process
people sit there and wait on their
computers and pray one day that they can
win the the lottery um for the Visas and
that changes people's lives but a lot of
people on that day are just they don't
get their visas and they realize you
know this is going to be my life for the
rest of my life and it's very hard on
them yeah because America is strict so I
know a lot of immigrants myself that
have came to the States or other
countries or immigrated from one place
to the other and built massively
successful businesses and a lot of that
comes stems from the work ethic part
that's why I'm so big on it uh I think
it's very brutal in every way shape or
form children and business regardless of
where you're from I think it's a lot
easier in the states of course but I I
really just hold the belief in my heart
very very strongly that anyone could do
anything that they want regardless the
circumstances if you have the will and
the power and drive to do so it isn't
just about the mentality oh yeah
yeah but that's not none we've all
experienced different parts of life very
privileged parts of life I think it's
very hard to speak on something unless
you've been there I've been to the
village in Nigeria I've seen how
difficult it is when you see it live
then you realize just how difficult it
is and just how privileged we are so
it's easy for us to be like they could
just start oil or steal or whatever but
then another thing you have to think of
is the government you know and yeah and
the different patriarchy systems and
just how they run and I fully believe
same thing whatever you put your mind to
you can do I'm a firm believer in that
but I also I'm very open and and
knowledgeable to the fact that where we
are at and the fact that we are teen
Millionaires and that's a title because
it's so rare just goes to show the fact
that it's vastly vastly impossible for
many people
it's crazy that how similar I feel like
we all have like similar experiences
even though we all come from different
backgrounds yeah I was shocked a lot of
times in my opinion shifted halfway
through the conversation because I
realized oh I didn't see it in that
light I have met a lot of successful
people but nobody my age and just to
meet these people it was there's a great
group of people we all click so well and
we're honestly thinking of planning a
trip